what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I cover this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and ring that
notification Bell the way you're gonna
be notified of my daily videos like the
video on your way in let's get started
Oh but before we start guys okay if you
guys want women to come up to you left
and right you think how do I get the
ladies I just want women to talk to me
I'm sick of approaching the chicks get
yourself a women shouldn't vote shirt
today let the women know men are
superior men are the smarter more
logical ones women should be in the
kitchen not voting so if you guys want
to get yourself a shirt the link is in
the description it's at the
audacitynetwork.store that's the
audacity Network dot store okay so today
we have a bunch of different topics
we're going to cover and again A lot of
times guys you're already know I get
like half my stories from Twitter
Pearl just tweets away you know tweet
tweet tweet tweet so I was shocked I was
scrolling through my timeline okay
and there was a woman with a big like
gash on her face
so it's just this big bump and she's
talking about how men don't protect her
and I just thought it was interesting
because I was thinking I'm like I've
never not really felt safe like I mean
there's maybe been one or two instances
but for the most of my life I felt
pretty safe I've never had a problem
you know getting guys to like protect
like women are pretty much offered
protection pretty freely and I think you
can really see it in this Society
because you know we're all walking
around naked at night I mean go to Vegas
go to any big city what'll you see half
naked women walking around at night if
we weren't you know openly protected in
this society would we feel comfortable
doing that
uh no but okay I'm gonna show you guys
the clip so this is the lady with the
bump on her face hit me and my face with
a brick and all these black men just
once and they don't give up
this man it hit me it would grab the
Rock and it hit me in my face and I
would have given my number oh y'all just
watched
have I ever done to anybody in my life
to deserve this
I never did anything in my life
burn anybody
literally a man asked me for my daughter
I said no and he he picked up a brick in
front of so many men and was like
what are you gonna do and I told all
these men like yo why this bag gotta
break all my face and he's he's holding
a brick and all these things is watching
then we we get a little more context
about what kind of person this lady is
so let's pull up the clip I I hope every
black woman is kissing another black
woman because we are the innate
protectors and the providers we protect
societies we protect communities with
our intellectual property with our lived
experiences with our breast milk with
our bodies we're the ones and the two
but it's not even a three three because
men are not providers and protectors not
innately because they only protect what
they possess but we protect everybody
and we provide baby okay now Clips go
viral on YouTube on Tick Tock whatever
and the problem we have with Clips is we
often don't see the full story with the
context and when I heard this story so
it just didn't add up like something was
weird to me because it didn't make sense
that all these men just watched her get
a brick thrown at her so I kind of sat
back you know Pearl just Waits I just
wait wait wait wait to see what what's
gonna happen What comes out and the
interesting thing with the Internet is I
really do think that we have been
manipulated
um like our reality has almost been
manipulated by the internet but the
great thing is
um the more people that are on the
internet the less like everything really
is just starting to come to light the
true like I'm a big believer that the
truth really does always come out so
then we we get a little more context
about what kind of person this lady is
so let's pull up the clips I was one of
the guys who was there that did not help
her when she was getting hit with a
brick right I feel like people need to
know the whole story before they start
commenting and they think they don't
understand or they don't know
you guys don't even remember who you
guys are trying to defend who you guys
are trying to speak up for this is the
same woman that was going around
smacking white people in the streets
She's Not Innocent she was actually
taunting the guy talk to her
[Music]
this is for the fact that you're a white
man and I'm a black woman I have less
privilege than you
thank you
wow
okay so there you have it folks
she's going around slapping people and
then gets mad when she gets hit back
it's like you can't make this [__] up
and now you're gonna say
really women are the innate protectors
and providers
do they protect their children when they
decide to leave the father of their kids
really really women which are mostly on
benefits women which typically of the
majority of the debt women which
generally have more useless jobs than
it's just like I don't know how Society
has let us live in this delusion for so
long where we genuinely think we are the
protectors and provide oh my God
oh no
oh no so I got I got very little
sympathy you're going around you're
going around hitting people
um and then you get hit back so you know
let's see what what Twitter says I I
find it weird she went back to make a
video and accused the men of not helping
her in order to shame their masculinity
some masculinity that y'all have been
running a smear campaign on us for
decades
I mean
is he wrong is he like we've been saying
for decades we don't like toxic
masculinity
and now
when when the men say okay [__] defend
yourself
first of all men protecting a random
woman in public is a privilege not a
right a privilege that is earned when
the woman in that Community carry
themselves like women and should be
protected and that is even without
knowing the full back story of the
incident without knowing the full
backstory and knowing how men think I
can guess that the area where the
incident happened is probably close to
the hood and the woman in that area have
a reputation of carrying themselves a
certain way
yeah
and you know very very nice facts King
very nice speaking facts today because
guys guys let's let's think about this
let's think about this
this chick's like twerking in the
streets slapping white people like
and this is a question for the women are
we entitled to protection do women
deserve protection do women deserve
provisioning and if we do do we have to
give anything in exchange
or is it simply I deserve but I have to
give nothing we give no children we give
no Purity we give no Youth and then we
whine and cry when we don't get the
protection [__] get a gun then no no
actually I don't know if I want that
lady holding a guy never mind never mind
do not watch this don't do it don't do
it and and this is the thing it's a
genuine conversation what do you have to
do to deserve protection and
provisioning and who do you deserve it
from
okay so speaking of the modern wives of
this generation so I had I had this
thought right and I was thinking our
generation of women is literally the
product of not one not two but three
generations of women not knowing how to
be wives
um and the reason I think this is
because I interviewed a woman that was
around 85. uh the other day and she was
telling me how in the 70s it was really
frowned upon not to be a feminist and
she was telling me how in the 70s you
know people would whisper to her in the
grocery stores uh saying that they're
not feminists either right so this tells
me that this propaganda and social
conditioning has been strong since at
least the 70s
um so that tells me that the 70s were
raised by another generation of women so
really this has been going on since the
40s and 50s and you know what's
interesting too I was thinking about
this
so what I see is the women in their 70s
and 80s
had more traditional skills so a lot of
them maybe stayed home a lot of them
cooked but they didn't have the mindset
of a wife where they didn't obey and
submit to their husbands so what I see
is that generation a lot of them ended
up separated but not divorced there is
still enough shame around divorce back
then where maybe they didn't go through
with it the Next Generation didn't give
a f they learned not to submit to the
men from the generation before right
then what they did is they went and
divorced their husbands you know they
they maybe got married first and then
divorced their husbands now our
generation is even getting married a lot
of Our Generation
Um the guys saw the shitty wives of the
previous generation and the truth of the
matter is there's always going to be
traditionalists in a society always like
there's always going to be outlier
traditional women but it's not the norm
and even the more traditional women that
you see that stay home
really don't obey their husbands like
that and I I think it's tough because
where where do women learn it from when
the generation before us is divorced
um I I would say 75 percent of marriages
in the generation before us is really
unhappy I think 25 is as is a high
estimate and I say this because really I
just think you can see this by the
reputation of marriage you know we can
go through study after study after study
you can get a liberal funded study or a
conservative funded study but I think
the real truth where you can come to
find truth in a society is when you look
at the reputation of wives why do we
have phrases like it's cheaper to keep
her
why do we have phrases like happy wife
happy life
uh why do we have phrases like she wears
the pants maybe it's because we have a
reputation of wives who wear the pants
who men don't want to stay with but they
will because they don't want to lose all
their money
um and where her her happiness
is what the whole relationship runs on
um this is about a hundred years of
propaganda so
speaking of which now it's interesting
because I think about in history
um and it's so interesting because we
have this group of women that I call
them the soft light life femininity
coaches and these are the women that
really rally around
um it really just doing nothing and
getting their nails done they want to be
the Housewives from the 50s and the
thing is guys a housewife is a generally
new phenomenon if we go back to
traditionalism guys ladies we never had
soft lives unless you were like an elite
woman it's like it's so delusional I
just can't even it's like we had like 20
years of Housewives
and like they think this was all of
history oh no you know most of our
ancestors a lot of them were farmers you
know what you would have did on a farm I
want you guys I'm you know I'm gonna
react to this one of these days a day in
the life of the Amish
what an Amish woman does in the day in a
day that would have been your life these
chicks get up at like 6 a.m they milk
the cows they scoop poop like this isn't
like a a soft life so it's really
interesting to see women get the
opportunity to live lives better than
most women did in all of history oh my
gosh dude can you imagine a woman from
like 500 years ago thinking like looking
at us and being like you're gonna you're
gonna piss away
you're whining because you have to work
20 hours a week in an air-conditioned
office
and therefore you can't obey your
husband like they would have looked at
us like their crate we're crazy they
would have been like [__] I'm scooping
poop I'm I'm I'm I'm making butter from
scrap like their lives were not easy so
I want to show you and what we do is we
see like women are just never happy and
so an example of this is it's rumored
that Joe Jonas and Sophie Turner are
getting divorced so a source and
remember this is all legit right so
assuming this is true
a source tells TMZ the reason Joe Jonas
filed for divorce from Sophie Turner she
likes to party he likes to stay home
they have very different Lifestyles
according to the divorce documents filed
by Joe Jonas also he says he had the
kids with him a hundred percent of the
time the last three months and so what
is what does the internet do they said
the man who married a 23 year old at 30.
yeah now it's the guy's fault for
wanting a hot young wife that's what
they always do they turn it and you know
guys this stuff doesn't surprise me
because we have women just we want to do
what's cool we want to do what's trendy
right we that's why we're always in the
latest fashion trends that's why we keep
hearing the same propaganda repeated
from women that's why we we have women
in all these super masculine jobs
because the Tomboy was cool the the you
know the masculine chick is always put
on a pedestal how many times have you
guys heard on my show them mentioned Kim
Kardashian I am so tired I am so tired
of hearing about Kim Kardashian and it's
because Kim Kardashian is a symbol of
what they want to be
um we're gonna see Kim Kardashian like
we're gonna see the end of her her luck
right you can only get away with this
[__] for so long but let's see Kim
Kardashian spent her 20s partying uh
what did we see with Kim Kardashian
first she married Ray J divorced him
then she did even better like she got
she got another high value guy Chris
Humphries divorced him then she got a
world-renowned superstar had four kids
with him divorced him then we see her
dating Pete Davidson
now look at we're gonna see her luck run
out these women can only do this for so
long
um but the point is women we do what's
cool and the the reason why like a
hundred years ago 22 year old chicks had
no problem being married
um they got married they stayed married
they had like seven kids because that
was cool and the anti-suffragettes which
were like they were the the modern day
version of feminists all the women that
wanted to vote guys they're not remember
we have to think in history there are
these crazy cat ladies and all the women
were hanging out sipping tea being like
I got my hot husband and they were The
Crazy Ones but now Housewives Are looked
at as The Crazy Ones so I get a lot of
pushback right because I know that the
numbers will tell you that the longest
marriages last between 25 and 35 right
and so if you look at the divorce rate
when women get married young they don't
tend to stay but the difference is the
culture because there we have a culture
which is always telling women we're
having so much fun at the club come to
the club Diane and then all the other
women are just like I mean we're all
like most women are just losers nowadays
so they're like oh you you need to be
single come out and that's why you see a
lot of women that have the opportunity
to live better lives than most women did
in all of history pissing it away and
she's gonna regret this the grass isn't
going to be greener on the other side
and occasionally when it is because some
women do get away occasionally right
some chicks get away with being single
mothers they get away with being
promiscuous they do like they do get
bailed out Kim Kardashian got bailed out
three times but the problem is women
revert back to what they know and so if
a women are practicing getting over men
and getting on to the next guy what do
you think she's gonna go back to doing
you know she didn't have any practice
working through the hard times she
didn't have any practice working through
problems so we have zero so we have zero
working through hard time skills and we
have a ton of skill skills of getting
over guys where does that leave modern
day women right now
it's very difficult to maintain healthy
relationships so and I think that the
reason you see 25 to 35 year old women
like last a little longer in marriages
which let's let's humble ourselves
um nobody lasts that long like nobody
like the average marriage is like eight
years like this is this is like saying
okay
um the 25 to 35 year old women
um stay married longer it's like it's
like competing for last place we have
like the worst reputation of wives ever
uh but we could look at a hundred years
ago when the wives reputation was better
uh when they were married longer they
seem to be happier they offered more
value
um than today so yeah we're just gonna
the hot chick does you know she does
have a lot of opportunity but
unfortunately women just squander it
they really just we just piss it away
and it would be so interesting I would
love I would love to get a what do you
call it a woman I wish I could like time
travel and get a chick from 500 years
ago and be like hey hey lady and she's
like working on the farm doing all this
hard stuff and say hey this would be
your life you know you got the air fryer
you got the the you have the um Roomba
you have all this stuff and all you
gotta do is not leave do you think you
could find a way to be happy they would
be like hell yeah
sign me up it's it's so crazy so today I
have a Reddit story and I was told not
to read this yet so I don't know what it
is
um but really we should just call Pearls
of Wisdom or I just give my life advice
all of the stuff
um
I'll give you my opinion so
you know on Reddit people ask for advice
and I'm I'm here to give I'm here for
you ladies
are these real these can't
my fiance cheated on me with my father
I never thought something like this
would happen to me but here we are it's
been a week since I found out that my
fiance L cheated on me with none other
than my father who I'll refer to as be
I've never used Reddit before but I've
seen stories from here on Tick Tock so I
thought I'd give a shot for any advice
you could provide I'll try to provide a
clear and precise account of what
happened but bear with me as it's still
fresh recounting it can be challenging
Ellen and I met during her freshman year
of college we were both living in the
same dorm building and our hometowns
were just two towns apart as a result I
often gave her a lift home during break
and after getting to know each other we
started dating our families were
close-knit
well obviously closer than you thought
like as we introduced each other
um to our respective families early on
they embraced us with open arms and our
relationships blossomed as I graduated
and I returned home and landed a great
job with good pay I visited eleter
School whenever I could and when she
finished college she moved in with me
both of us secured positions at
companies near our hometown with
excellent pay three years into living
together I proposed and we began wedding
planning everything seemed perfect that
was until it all unraveled in hindsight
there were subtle signs I overlooked
things that I dismissed as my father
just trying to bond with my fiance
he frequently called her and if I happen
to be around they'd brush it off as
discussions about upcoming family
gatherings or in innocent matters I even
once answered Al's phone when my father
called while she was in the shower he
sounded surprised and agitated when he
realized it was me he claimed he wanted
to talk to Al about my mother's upcoming
birthday but in retrospect it was a
feeble excuse the fateful day arrived
like any other Al had a day off she
prepared breakfast for both of us and I
left for work she kissed me goodbye and
we exchanged mundane text throughout the
day discussing dinner plans and
household chores uncharacteristically I
forgot some essential paperwork for a 3
pm meeting and decided to return home
during lunch to retrieve it upon
arriving home I noticed that a car
resembled my father's in our parking lot
but I didn't think much of it and
proceeded inside what I encountered was
like a scene from a movie where a man
returns home early to catch his spouse
in an affair a cliche but a harsh
reality clothes were thrown about
leading to my bedroom and faint moans in
my apartment I stood Frozen at the
doorway a tumultuous mix of anger
sadness and disgust consuming me finally
I snapped out of my stupor and began
recording The Surreal scene with my
phone I gathered the discarded clothes
and threw them into the hallway and then
ventured towards my bedroom turning on
the lights
they both jumped in surprise at the
sudden illumination and to my shock it
was my father lying in bed with Elle
anger surged within me my father
realizing I was recording panicked and
reach for my phone I warned him to stop
but he didn't hear me or didn't care in
a fit of rage I struck him in the jaw
causing him to slump to this floor Al
shrieked and I directed the camera at
her questioning her loyalty after a
brief moment my father regained
Consciousness I informed them that I had
just returned to retrieve some paperwork
for work and that I would be back soon
if they were still there when I returned
I threatened to share the incriminating
video with everyone they knew I
terminated the recording looked at my
father and declared that he was no
longer my father I suggested he go home
and talk to my mother because I would be
having a conversation with her very soon
I sat in my car for a while lost in my
thoughts until my boss called asking
about my whereabouts I assured her I was
on my way back upon meeting her in the
office to hand over the paperwork she
noticed something was amiss my
disheveled appearance raised her concern
I showed her the video and she watched
it in silence she had met Al a few times
but had never encountered my father
finally she grasped at the gravity of
the situation Not only was my fiance
cheating but it was with my own father
my boss offered to give me some time off
but I declined insisting I needed to
return to work I attended a meeting and
put on a facade of Norm mulsi afterward
my boss approached me bewildered by my
ability to mask my emotions I provided
no explanation retreated to my office
and later returned home finally alone
for the first time in a while thank you
for reading I apologize for the lengthy
account but sharing this has been
therapeutic I'm at a loss for what to do
next I certainly need to vacate this
apartment as I cannot bear to be here
any longer
additionally I must get tested for STDs
and have my hand examined as I suspect
it may be broken
I don't even
I I don't even
what
I don't think this was advice like I
think he did
I I do think the dad deserved to be
punched in the face you know they always
say I take the women's side
oh sorry I mean they always say I take
the men's side but I mean sometimes this
is crazy
um
yeah
um I would never talk to my dad again if
he did that if I was in his shoes
um
you never talk to her again I'm glad he
took the video and made them leave
I got I got no advice
I just got a lot of sympathy Jesus
Christ
wow
um I hope that wasn't real I hope
someone made that up but this is the
thing like
nothing surprises me anymore but nothing
it just
it doesn't surprise me that a chick
would try to do better in her head
no not really I think I'm distraught I
think I'm distraught after that
wow all right so
um
guys this is a little outside of my
normal programming okay but I this was
insane so I saw a tweet
about a a Delta Airlines flight from
Atlanta to Barcelona was forced to turn
around Friday after a significant
medical issue on the plane we've had a
passenger who had diarrhea all the way
through the plane so they want to come
back to Atlanta
can you imagine being that person
with the whole plane replying to the
post a traveler identified as John Hurt
wrote both my re both my wife and I were
on the flight it was a mess the pilots
made the right decision to turn around
the ground crew ripped out the carpet
and put a new one in considering the
circumstances the ground crew did a
great job along with the attendance and
the pilot
my partner was on that flight it was
pretty bad another person identified as
DW posted on X adding that it smelled
horrible without elaborating on the
nature of the incident Delta told USA
Today Delta flight 194 on September 1st
from Atlanta to Barcelona returned to
Atlanta following an onboard medical
issue our teams worked as quickly and
safely as possible to get our customers
to our final destination we sincerely
apologize to our customers for the delay
and inconvenience to their travel plans
Delta said the 336 customers on board
the Airbus a350 made it to their
destination without further incident the
following day the flight arrived eight
hours and six minutes behind schedules
they had to have had like a medical
issue
wow I feel I actually have so much
simple oh can you imagine being that
person
oh they had they had to have had like
something wrong with them to
I wonder how long they were flying until
they turned it around like I wonder if
they flew for like an hour and then had
to turn around
oh I can't even imagine being that
person oh oh you would want to die
oh my gosh you know
I'm starting to like I'm starting to
think buses are the are the way moving
forward there's a lot of trains in
Europe I'm starting to think maybe
that's the way that's the move you can
get off at any time
um Okay so
Tucker Carlson is interviewing a man who
claims he had sex with and did drugs
with the former president Barack Obama
let's pull the clip guy who's in town
for the night and it sounds like you're
looking to party yes hold up in a bar
outside and there's this guy that's
introduced to me as Barack Obama I had
given Barack 250 to pay for Coke I start
putting a line on a CD tray to snort and
next thing I know he's got a little pipe
and he's smoking so I just started
rubbing my hand along his thigh to see
where it was going and it went the
direction I had intended it to go even
though you had sex with him twice you
did cocaine with him watch them smoke
crack twice you had no idea who he was I
had no idea who he was since that's the
obvious question what was Obama like on
the crack
um is it your sense that that sewer bomb
is just transactional or if he's
bisexual or like what is this it
definitely wasn't barack's first time
and I would almost be willing to bet you
it wasn't as long
the guy's running for president and
credible information comes out that he's
smoking crack and having sex with dudes
that seems like a story well it would be
a story if the media really cared about
telling people the true Tucker Carlson
okay it's basically interviewing a
crackhead about having sex with Obama
now clearly this is not a credible
Source not at all but I'm so here for
Tucker Carlson's New Era like this is
hilarious
um you know and it's all right guys I
gotta I gotta talk about Michelle Obama
okay Michelle Obama everybody will
always say she's like Trans on Twitter I
don't know where I literally don't know
where this rumor came from but everybody
says Michelle Obama is a man and I gotta
be honest guys
people started saying the same thing
about me I know I know it's like I'm
like the epitome of just the red-headed
whatever and yeah so then I'm like okay
but you know if a chick gets a little
muscle I'm an athlete they kind of just
start to like say that you know but now
these crackheads are coming out and
saying Obama likes dudes now do I really
think this is real
not really
but this is sure as hell gonna be an
entertaining interview
um
and I'm really excited to see where like
Tucker Carlson goes with the media
because really I really think before
politicians media personalities could
have dirty laundry and no one would
really know but it's getting harder and
harder to hide stuff especially the more
of a free speech platform we get
and the more phones are just everywhere
like you really can't go anywhere
nowadays without being recorded how
crazy is that
um you you really can't uh like you even
see like when people go missing it's
always like you can basically get their
whereabouts and you know there's pros
and cons to it on on one hand like you
lose privacy but on the other hand the
truth always comes out so I
Tucker Carlson's new era is just gonna
be hilarious so I'm excited for it but
um let me know what you guys think in
the comments make sure you like the
video uh And subscribe to the channel
um bring your notification bells and get
yourself a women shouldn't vote shirt so
you can get all the hotties all the
ladies coming up to you like the video
on your way out and I'll talk to you
next time